hello there today deepmind published a
new paper called Alpha tensor this is a
system that speeds up Matrix
multiplications of all things now I know
it sounds a bit boring to speed up
Matrix multiplications that's like not
as flashy as some of the other things
deepmind has done but since Matrix
multiplications are at the foundation of
pretty much all of science a speed up of
10 20 or even one percent in this domain
is huge and can make the whole world
better off this is really cool because
it also shows how the mind took their
ideas their original ideas from
something like alphago and pull them
through all the way to now where they
have real applications in science and
that's cool and it it's a bit a
validation of this idea because a lot of
people said initially when deepmind
focused that much on games and things
like this that uh it's it's just for
press it's just flashy and to a certain
degree it is but definitely it is also
applicable because you can frame a lot
of things as games not just Atari and
chess and go in fact matrix
multiplication as we'll see can be
framed as a single player game
essentially called tensor game and then
you can apply much the same techniques
to it as you do solving chess or solving
go so we're going to look at this paper
as I said this was published by deepmind
it was published in the Journal of
Nature and yeah it's it's a big deal I
think it's a big deal and uh yeah let's
let's dive in we're going to look at
what the problem actually is how it
works and what the actual results are hi
this video is sponsored by assembly AI
assembly AI does real time and batch
audio transcription of audio and video
files powered by the latest advances in
artificial intelligence so if you are a
developer or work for a company that's
looking to get more out of your audio or
video data through transcription and
audio intelligence assembly AI is the
best place to go not only do they have a
user interface where you can just upload
stuff but they do have a very powerful
API but transcription isn't all they do
once your audio is described they
actually post process it in many
different optional ways so they can do
things like speaker classification or
annotations of various forms inside of
your audio one feature I'd like to
particularly highlight today is the
sentiment analysis now we're all
familiar with sentiment analysis but
have you ever done it on a piece of
transcribed audio not only can you infer
it from the text but you can actually
infer it from the tones of voices the
breaks people take and much more in
order to use this feature with assembly
AI simply provide the sentiment analysis
equals true in your request and assembly
AI will do the rest for you you'll get
the result as a neat Json output and can
take it from there so if you're
interested head on over to assembly AI
use the link in the description to let
them know that I sent you they are the
single API to transcribe and understand
audio they do so in batch and in real
time via websocket they accept all kinds
of audio and video formats and they do
so in over 15 languages give it a try
and thank you very much to assembly AI
for sponsoring this video and now let's
get into the video
[Music]
so the paper is called discovering
faster matrix multiplication algorithms
with reinforcement learning
as I already said if you don't if you
don't know what matrix multiplication is
we not not go too much into this here uh
suffice to say a matrix is just kind of
like a a bunch of numbers and there's a
specific way of multiplying these bunch
of numbers with a bunch of other numbers
and you get a bunch of other numbers so
essentially a matrix is a square box of
numbers and we have ways of multiplying
them and that's all of science there
there you go
uh so what's the the actual deal so if
we go through it and I'm going to make
this a tiny bit bigger right here so if
we have a matrix like A1 how they call
it A2 A3 A4
and we multiply that by a matrix of B B1
B2 B3 B4 right the classic algorithm of
doing Matrix Matrix multiplication goes
something like this if I want to have
this the entry up here then I look at
the row I take that row of this Matrix I
look at the column I take the column of
this Matrix I compute the inner product
so that's kind of like uh A1 B1 plus A2
B2 right that's the that's the
thing and I do it for every single
component right here so A1 B1 Plus
A2 no B3 B3 is that you see I already
failed
so I do that and then I compute this one
by using this row and this column and so
on and you can see there's a bunch of
stuff coming together mainly additions
and multiplications so we have an
addition right here
and we have the multiplications
obviously in between the components now
it just turns out that on our Hardware
that we use in Silicon addition is much
much faster than multiplication so the
bulk of the time that a processor is
going to spend on doing Matrix
multiplications is actually doing
uh the individual multiplications
between the numbers the additions are
not the issue so the question is how
many multiplications do we need in order
to to uh to multiply two matrices now
it's sort of the classic algorithm if I
have matrices of size n by n then I'm
going to need about o n to the to the
third I think
multiplications of achieving that
so I need to do every row with every
column and each of those inner products
is again of size n right so those are
those are my uh the square is everything
with everything and then inside of each
of these of the inner products I again
have n multiplications
now what is already astounding is that
because you would think this is right I
need this I need to do all of these
multiplications to compute uh all of
these numbers like I have no choice if I
want to compute these numbers somewhere
there needs to be a multiplication
between this number and this number and
this number
oh
sorry this and you see I'm I'm terrible
at this so between this number and this
number and between this number and this
number and that's naturally two
multiplications I can't get around it
and so I need to compute two
multiplications for each of the four
entries right here that's two to the
third that's eight like and I can tell
you it's faster than that there is a way
of doing it faster in fact it's
displayed right here so you can see I
hope you can see it's not all too big
but if you compute this term right here
M1 M1 is a A1 Plus A4 times B1 plus B4
so I would first go let me how do I have
another color yes I would first go and
add those two numbers
and then I would add those two numbers
no multiplication yet and then I would
simply multiply the addition of the two
numbers that's just one multiplication
between two numbers right not an inner
product or anything so that's that's a
term that I'll call M1 and then I do
this a bunch of other times you can see
here it gets kind of tricky you subtract
subtraction is essentially addition as
well so it's really cheap but each of
these terms right here is just one
scalar multiplication and then from
these intermediate terms I can compute
down here you can see again only
additions the final product and if you
calculate this all out you'll actually
see yes it actually works it works out
we can try to follow one of these things
and oh yeah the catch is there's only
seven there's only seven one of these
multiplications and that seems like
magic right it seems like it shouldn't
be it shouldn't be possible but I'm
going to convince you that it is with a
simple example in fact you already know
this if you for example take the
following so take a squared minus B
squared right this is a very common
formula in sort of high school algebra
so that is a times a minus B times B two
multiplications right one multiplication
here one multiplication here now I can
rewrite this as you know
to a plus b times a minus B and look at
that there's now just one multiplication
you're like that that's literally it but
you might say well it's still the same
thing yes what you're doing is you're
trading off addition
for multiplication in fact when you
calculate this out as you know this is a
squared
um plus a B minus a b
uh minus B squared all right and then
these terms here cancel out so in fact
hidden in all of this are one two three
four multiplications however by clever
Arrangement uh it's actually the two
multiplications that we
that we started with out here so by
cleverly arranging things right you and
and and and and then later so this would
be the the intermediate term one I guess
they call that M1 this would be the
intermediate term M2 by cleverly
arranging these intermediate terms so
that later uh multiplying them actually
cancels out some of the terms you can
have it such that one scalar
multiplication with more additions than
you would usually do in fact results in
the same result as four or respectively
two multiplications if you cross out the
canceling terms but with fewer additions
and that's exactly what we want so you
know this here already and the same
principle carries over to the Matrix
World in fact when you look at one of
these entries we can quickly look at one
let's look at C2 right here
so C2 is m 3 plus M5 well what's M3 M3
is this one right here plus M5 well you
already see what's uh C2 C2 is here so
that's this row
times this column so we need an A1 Plus
A1 B2 in there somehow so A1 is here
times B2 that's this term
and we also need an A2 B4
well A2 and B4 B4 and A2 Dots here and
now all we need is that the other terms
cancel well there is a B4 times A1 and
look there is an A1 times B4 with a
minus sign they cancel
so that's the general principle of why
it is possible seem the seemingly
impossible task of speeding up matrix
multiplication why it is possible and
again the speed up isn't because of some
math magic
the speed up is because we only care
about the number of multiplications
because our Hardware is bounded by the
number of multiplications and because we
can trade off multiplications for
additions right we we don't we don't
make stuff we don't make speed appear
out of nothing we simply customize it
more to our Hardware
so
how do we now formulate this as some
sort of game right it seems to be that
the game is to find these formulas right
here to find this algorithm this is an
algorithm this is valid for any
multiplications of two by two matrices
any of these you can multiply like these
will give you the correct result
independent of the actual coefficients
but how do we set up a system that could
find this right here if you as a human
were to find this you'd be like let me
try well it turns out there is a neat
formalization of finding these
algorithms as a tensor decomposition
so for that you have to look at the
tensor right here now
I don't know if you can see this the
rendering of the PDF here is a bit small
but I'm going to try to keep it zoomed
in like that
this is a three-dimensional tensors you
might say wait I thought we were dealing
with two dimensional matrices well yes
but
the problem of finding the algorithm of
multiplying two-dimensional matrices can
actually be phrased or let me let me
other than that let me say the the
multiplication of two-dimensional
matrices can be phrased as a
three-dimensional tensor and then
finding the algorithm is a decomposition
problem of that tensor so let me show
you what I mean here you have that
tensor you have the Matrix a unrolled
here into its components you see A1 A2
A3 A4 you have the Matrix B unrolled in
this Dimension into its components and
in the last Dimension so this is the in
the last Dimension this Dimension here
you have the resulting Matrix unrolled
this is a matrix this right here it only
has components 0 or 1. it has no other
numbers in it there's just either a zero
or a one
now uh the ones you can see here colored
in solid blocks and whenever there's a
one in this tensor it means that that's
um that's a a step you have to do so
ideally there should be a one for every
entry in the C
Dimension right here so you can see C1
how do we do it we go look aha okay this
block here is the entry for C1
now
what do we need to do
we look at the other dimensions so this
corresponds to B1 and A1 right a this is
this Dimension B1 is this Dimension so
this block being solid it means in order
to get C1 we need to multiply A1 and B1
now that's not enough there's also going
to be another entry for C1 namely as you
can see down here this is also on the
dimension of on the axis uh that
corresponds to C1 and it in turn
corresponds again to A1 this Dimension
but B3
so we have to multiply A1 by B3 also to
get C1 and if you look C1 it's
um
this times
this right now I'm so A1 times B1
now it's A2
hmm
I might be confused here
or is the drawing confused
it should be A2 multiplied by B3 oh yes
of course obviously sorry yeah this is
A2 this slice here is A2 I I was dumb so
it's a three-dimensional tensor I'm not
used to these kind of higher level
mathematical stuff that scares me
but you can see using this tensor we can
fill in the blocks that we know
corresponds to Matrix Matrix
multiplication entries and this is just
a classic algorithm right I'm doing
nothing fancy here I'm just applying the
high school matrix multiplication
algorithm saying like Okay what do I
need to get for this I need to get you
know these two plus these two and for
every multiplication here I make one
entry into this tensor so at the
location that I want C1 is the result
I'm going to make one entry here for the
first multiplication I'm gonna make one
entry here for the second multiplication
and I'll get a tensor
now
it turns out it turns out that
a low rank decomposition of this tensor
will exactly give me an algorithm to
perform this multiplication in fact any
decomposition of this tensor will do
that so I can decompose a tensor I can
decompose a matrix but also a tensor
into individual components now for a
matrix you may know
for example that I if I have a matrix a
I can I can write it as a sum of outer
products of vectors u i
v i right there's various and sorry out
there product
so every component here is going to be
some sort of a vector multiplied by some
sort of other Vector so the outer
product will give me a matrix but the
Matrix is of rank 1 and then I add many
of these matrices and I'll give me the
original Matrix I can do that with any
Matrix right you might know some special
cases of these decompositions for
example spectral decomposition usually
extracts also some sort of a scalar
right here and then makes these two
orthogonal so there are various ways of
how to do this but in our case any
decomposition of this Matrix will give
us an algorithm
and it's going to be a valid algorithm
because it's a valid decomposition of
the it's a valid decomposition of the
tensor therefore uh
if I apply that algorithm I will get the
correct matrix multiplication here on
the right hand side you can see one such
decomposition that corresponds to this
algorithm right here there can be
various different algorithms all with
either the same or more or less steps
which correspond to various ways of
decomposing that tensor
so the tensor specifically you can see
here Matrix is U V and W and
specifically the decomposition uh goes
as the Matrix how do we call that
maybe M no T they call it t
so specifically that Matrix T is going
to be decomposed into individual parts
of vectors u i
outer product with VI outer product with
uh w i
again I can do this in any case these
are going to be rank 1 three-dimensional
tensors if I if I do that right one
vector one vector and one vector
gives me a rank one three-dimensional
tensor if I add many of these uh um I'll
I'll get more rank more tensor
and if that addition results
in this tensor right here that means I
have found a decomposition of that
tensor
and this also directly corresponds to an
algorithm let's look at that how that
works so if assume that I have such a
decomposition what I can do is I can
take the first Vector here and the first
Vector here and that will give me kind
of the components that I need to compute
so the first Vector here you can see
corresponds to A1 Plus A4 so I have to
take A1 and A4 the two entries with the
ones
and then of the B Matrix I have to take
B1 and B4 this thing right here
and I have to build
this thing so I have to multiply them
multiply them oopsie multiply that those
and that will become m one and that will
result in M1 M1 I'll remember for later
so m one similarly the second columns
will become M2 M3 and so on
and then later I'll go and look at my
Matrix W and now I'm going to look at
the rows of the Matrix w
and this row tells me which one of the M
terms I need to combine together so 1
well that's actually good better visible
one M1 plus 1 M4 minus 1 M 5 plus 1 M 7.
that's exactly this row right here which
is going to give me C1 as an entry
so if I have a decomposition I can just
read off the algorithm
and just to understand like a tiny bit
more what's happening right here I also
thought we'd look at the same uh entry
we did before so let's look at C2 how do
I get C2 well I need
um
M3 not
no I was I wanted to do something
different I wanted to let's stay at the
C1 and let's look at what that actually
does like how this how this outer
product even looks right because I still
can see that maybe some people have a
hard time visualizing what's happening
so
I just told you how to do the algorithm
but I also showed you well there's this
decomposition right here
and technically that First Column of all
of these vectors should correspond to
the first entry in that decomposition
but how does that look
well
if I take u and v and I build the outer
product essentially what I have to do is
I have to take U and let's put U into
the column here
just into the row let's transpose
you and I outer product it with v so I
need to take one time U then zero time u
in the next column then 0 times u in the
next column and then one time u in the
last column that's this right and now I
want the outer product with W here okay
I'll go into the third dimension so I
take one time that slice that I just
computed
that's my front then 0 times 0 times
that's like zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero
and you you can like it's a cube you you
fill in the back yourself and then I
take it one time again so one zero zero
one zero zero one and so on so that's
gonna be a cube with ones at the corners
ones
and uh
everything else is zero so this cube
with ones at the corners and everything
else is zero is rank one is a rank one
3D tensor because it can be decomposed
into the outer product of three vectors
not every 3D tensor is can do that only
rank one 3D tensors
and now at if we if we go through all of
these columns right here we do all of
that and we add all of these cubes that
we're going to get together then we get
back to this thing right here which
means that again it's a valid
decomposition
and you can already see here
two of the corners are actually correct
so this corner right here
yes we just we we just made it right
this corner right here is already done
it's this corner here
that we already we have it right and the
corner down here
we have it too here
so if the all of this is correct right
then it should be that in none of the
other columns we're going to modify
these Corners again so let's quickly
check that for the the top left corner
here so the one one one entry that's
this this and this so
none of these things so these should be
these are one one one here which gives
us that result so in no other column
should we get an entry here there's
always going to be one zero somewhere
and you can see right there's a zero
here in fact here too there's one here
and here there's one here
there's one here one here and two here
so good right this this is the only
place where that's modified so that
corner is the direct
is this corner in the final result
however if we look at another corner
for example this one here well this one
is zero in the final tensor but here we
have it as a one so our hypothesis is
that in some of the other columns this
must be kind of reverted right much like
this component right here is reverted
later uh or you know however you want to
want to watch it this needs to be
canceled out somewhere
so let's go and find out where it is
canceled out so currently this is a one
why is it a one well it's a one because
a one is here a one is here right
because we're in other corner now and
the one is here so Dimension one
dimension four dimension one here
our hypothesis is that this is going to
be somewhere later subtracted again
well okay there's a zero here a zero
here so that's not not it we have one
minus one and one here so three
candidates
there's as oh no we're in the bottom row
uh there is a zero here so not this
column
ah there is a one and a one here okay
this already looks promising now there's
a zero here so it's not this column so
look at this column there is a one
boom there is a one down here you can't
see it anymore but it's there
and there is a negative one here so this
outer product of the last column is
going to result in negative one as a as
this corner of the cube right so in its
Cube It's going to have a negative one
here instead of a one and if we add
those together remember we add those all
together
because it's a tensor decomposition
we get 0 at this place right here
and if we now go and look okay into C4
this is yes this is C4
at the last column we should
uh see that
no wait
no that's not something that's not
something we can we can see right here
sorry for that
um in any case I hope you can imagine a
little bit in how that goes so you build
up these these these things these cubes
which are rank which are low rank but
quite complex right and you then add
them together and the correct things
need to cancel out such that you get
back this thing right here because this
thing actually corresponds to the
original Matrix Matrix multiplication
and if you find a correct uh
decomposition then that also corresponds
to the multiplication but the
decomposition also gives you directly an
algorithm to perform this multiplication
a different one than the original tensor
and now it's only can you find a
decomposition where this Dimension right
here
is very low right now we can all find
decompositions where this Dimension is
really high because we can just consider
the individual entries of the original
tensor and for each one of them we
construct such columns right so that
it's one at exactly that place however
if we do it in a smarter way we can do
with less columns and thereby our
decomposition has a lower Rank and
thereby we need less multiplications
because each column corresponds to
exactly one multiplication okay that was
long-winded but I hope you get a little
bit of the idea of why it is even
possible to speed up Matrix Matrix
multiplication of how we represent a
matrix matrix multiplication as a 3D
tensor and why a decomposition of that
tensor gives us a new algorithm to
perform the same thing and then
that the rank of the decomposition
will is directly directly corresponding
to the
to the number of multiplications we need
so the goal is to get a low number of
terms in that decomposition
so what does now how how do you do this
as a game
uh they formulate this as okay this is
all we probably talked about this yada
yada
and again this is not this is not this
has nothing to do with what numbers are
in The Matrix right the fact that
there's zero and one here just
corresponds to the algorithm itself so
we're working with the algorithm we're
not working with the numbers also you
can see there's just zeros and ones and
minus ones here but this can be in fact
any decomposition this can be negative
3.5 100
000 and so on but for Simplicity and
because of some symmetries I assume
um you can actually limit that in fact
they do limit it to negative two
negative one zero one and two because of
numerical stability and
um because well I don't know maybe maybe
there's a super small smart algorithm
with uh negative 3.7 as a as a
coefficient but in any case
they now apply Alpha 0 to this so they
have a few special uh Network
architecture tricks
um where they exploit some properties of
linear algebra
for example
they say well
the if you change the basis of a linear
operation then it's it's kind of still
the same uh problem so it's you can you
can change the basis of matrices and
it's still the essentially represents
the same transformation however uh to
this algorithm this is like a new thing
because now that there's different
numbers right the the algorithm looks
different because it's it's sort of a
transformation of one another now
there's one class of research papers
that say we're going to build our neural
network to be invariant to that
but there's an entirely other class and
this one here falls under that with that
says well great so that's kind of like
uh much more training data if one
training sample corresponds to like many
many many
uh I can make many training samples out
of one that's free data augmentation so
they use change of bases here which is a
fundamental property or a fundamental
action in linear algebra to create more
training data they also say well look uh
while decomposing a 3D tensor is really
hard
constructing one is really easy we just
sample three vectors we add we make the
outer product we do that a bunch of
times we add those things together and
we have a three-dimensional tensor that
now you can try to decompose right so
they can also create synthetic training
data all very smart tricks in order to
uh feed their system with more data to
train them so the system is going to be
trained on exactly providing these
decompositions we'll look at how in just
a bit the last thing I want to do is the
neural network architecture that they
analyze things with here it's
Transformer based who would have thought
that now
um interestingly they say they
generalize axial attention they have a
diagram of their architecture down here
and you don't need to know yet what they
do with the architecture but essentially
uh this is a reinforcement learning
algorithm so the input here is the
current tensor and the history of uh
tensors which I find really interesting
that they also consider the the history
of things
this goes into some sort of a torso or a
body or whatnot then out comes some sort
of embedding this goes into a policy and
a value head you might be familiar with
all of this if you're familiar with
reinforcement learning the action space
here as you know we've discussed are to
select three vectors one of you one of v
and one of w that
so you select one of The Columns of the
thing we just saw right we uh so there
are
U V and W which should ultimately give
you as the sum of outer products this
Tau right here and an action is you'd
provide one of these Columns of each of
the entries so one column at a time this
is an action the next step in the game
would be to determine this thing The
Next Step would be to determine the next
column
the game is over
whenever the multiplication here is
actually equal
so you can formulate that in a different
way by saying uh
oh sorry
you can formulate this in a different
way by saying well the Tau should be the
sum of u i outer product v i outer
product w i right
so once I have U1 W1 and V1 I can
subtract that right so this is step one
of the game step two would be Tau minus
U1 outer product V1 outer product W1 1
not I one must be equal to the sum of I
equals 2 to you know potentially
Infinity
of UI so once I have one I once I have
an action which is three vectors I can
subtract that from my original tensor
and then the goal is to find the next
action to subtract from the original
tensor the game is over exactly then
when this here is equal to zero right it
can it can go negative in some entries
as you saw but if all the entries of the
tensor are zero then the game is over
this is obviously a discrete problem and
it is in fact NP hard if the tensor is
of an order higher than two so this is
not an easy task and the action space is
huge right you don't just emit one uh
number you don't you emit the in three
vectors each with their respective
entries so that is a ginormous action
space actually much larger action space
than something like chess or go so
that's why this problem is particularly
difficult
this is a finer architecture finer
diagram of the architecture here of the
the Torso so what they do is they take
the history here of the um
of the tensors that came along in the in
the last time steps and they project it
down to this grid you can see right here
this is s
um
s by S by TS T being the number of steps
so TS plus one they project it down in
various ways onto these grid layers then
they have linear layers projecting not
projecting
um linear layers transforming this into
some sort of C dimensional Vector you
can see here you reduce the time
Dimension down to the C Dimension uh
after that you have these what they call
attentive modes and at the end some sort
of output now the attentive modes I I
hope that's this right here policy head
tag oh no
um the attentive modes are they say they
as I said they generalize a form of
axial attention
and then here the way they do the
actions in as in common in reinforcement
learning you take the embedding that
comes out of the Torso here and this is
kind of like an auto regressive language
model if you will that outputs the next
action so here you have no action at all
um
and then you output
a policy and the policy is a
distribution over your action space
there's also an output to the value head
and you do that these are here next
action next action and so on
uh the value head is simply you take
that embedding from the policy head
shove it through some neural network and
you can train all of that end to end
again if you don't know Alpha zero or
reinforcement learning in general I have
many videos on that so the gist is that
you pair this network here
um which we just saw is this one in kind
of finer detail you pair this with a
so-called Monte Carlo tree search
so in order to solve these games you're
in some sort of state right at the
beginning your Matrix is full you
haven't subtracted anything or your
chessboard is at the initial State and
then you consider different moves to do
uh and for each move that you could do
you then if you do it you can consider
more moves right or your opponent can
consider more moves and for each of
those moves again you consider more
moves so this is a tree search algorithm
now the alpha zero style Monte Carlo
Tree Search Works in a way that the
policy and value head
um policy and value
functions of your neural network they
will guide you through this tree search
so they will suggest to you nodes here
that are more likely for you to be able
to win the game again winning in this
case means getting a successful tensor
decomposition
and some that are and say well now this
one you shouldn't even try you shouldn't
even Explore that direction so that
saves you from considering all those
possibilities narrowing it down onto
just a few that you then go explore
further and then and you can ask your
network again well if I were to go here
what would you do next well I would
maybe try this one or this one okay and
you only need to search those
and you iteratively train this such that
once you actually play the game and you
do this and you go down and at some
point you finish the game either you
reach the zero tensor which means win
reward of one or you uh you you don't
finish the game which is a bad so very
low reward
um then that feeds back into all of
these things so it feeds back training
the neural network to make better
predictions in fact the reward isn't
just zero or one they do give and I
believe they describe it somewhere
they do give a negative one reward for
every step that's being done
nope
well I don't exactly know where they
describe that
but
yes there
so they say there's a negative
a reward of negative one
or for every step taken
to encourage finding the shortest path
this is much better than just giving
zero or one reward for one this actually
encourages a low the low rank
decomposition on the other hand
um it also provides a denser reward
signal so you don't have to it's not
like you you win either win because this
problem is super difficult right and by
to stumble by chance upon this would be
not really it would be like really lucky
and the reward would be super sparse so
they say well you get a reward for every
step taking a negative reward so better
take fewer steps
and then on top of that they also pair a
um
a supervised reward from this synthetic
demonstrations because in the synthetic
data not only can they generate data
they actually know the correct steps to
do so they can train the neural networks
in a supervised fashion they can say hey
here's the situation and we already know
because we made the problem we already
know what steps you should take
so that gets
on top do they say that somewhere here
maybe not
somewhere they describe the the loss in
detail where they say well our loss is
this plus the supervised loss in any
case that's how they do it and the whole
algorithm is essentially here
they start out with a game which is one
of the original tensors they change the
basis to make it to augment the data to
make it into one never seen before they
do the Monte Carlo tree search
to determine the first step to do so the
tree search is just kind of imaginary
you kind of think ahead once you know
what to do you do the step then you do
the tree search again and so on until
you're at the end of the episode that
represents a played game either you win
or you lose you take your reward and use
that to train
so this is learning you put that in your
buffer of games you also have your
synthetic data right here you sample
these things you train your your neural
network either from a synthetic data
point or from one that you've already
played in order to predict better what
actions to do which is the policy that's
guiding you through the network and also
the value head which is a function that
estimates the value of each node in the
network right here also helps you to to
helps to guide you
so the policy head in fact guides you to
to which path you want to go down and
then you don't always want to go down
all the way so at some point you just
cut off and you ask the value head well
what do you how much you think this
state is worth
you aggregate that all on top and you
look at the top level of all your
available actions which one looks the
most promising and that's what you go
with so that's MCTS Alpha zero style in
a nutshell
the results the results are pretty
astounding in that you can see right
here for small Matrix Matrix
multiplications
um they actually do find better
algorithms and you would think that
something like multiplying four by four
matrices would be kind of figured out by
now but no
the uh best known algorithm had a
um 49
multiplication decomposition and now we
have a 47
multiplication decomposition now this is
uh modular so as far as I understand
this is over a finite field this is not
a real matrices but I think
for real
I'm actually not
super sure
for real matrices I believe the thing
down here counts
so
for example multiplying three by four
matrices to four by five matrices
previous best known rank 48 now 47 again
doesn't seem like much but is uh and as
you go higher this gets more drastic
multiplying four by five to five by five
matrices uh there are four
multiplications Less in the algorithm
that Alpha tensor found you can see in
the diagram right here as you go up in
rank so best rank known for given
problems and here Improvement in rank
how much Alpha tensor improves see
there's a clear diagonal line and that
is maybe a bit obvious because uh us
humans we can't really come up with well
give me an 800 multiplication
decomposition of some tensor
uh that's it's just kind of a bit above
our league so what we do is we kind of
break it down in small problems and then
just kind of recursively apply these
strategies and if you can consider a
problem in its entirety then obviously
have a better chance of just you know
canceling out some things somewhere at
some point
or or are these just the symmetric up
here okay that could be as well
um these are the symmetric and then
these are finite versus uh modular sorry
modular versus versus standard versus
real good
but the others can be real I'm just
gonna stop talking now another cool
thing you can do is you may have noticed
nothing in the base algorithm actually
says that you know low rank is the goal
that's simply us putting this into the
reward we say well for every step you do
you get a negative reward Ergo the
algorithm is encouraged to take as few
steps as possible however we can just do
something else this is black box right
this there's nothing
the algorithm just gets this at the end
and it needs to learn this implicitly so
we can swap it out we can say actually
we're not that interested in lowest
amount of steps we're going to swap that
out or in this case we're going to add
another reward on top of that
um that says well
we modify the reward they say right here
we provide an additional reward at the
terminal state so you only get this
additional reward after you actually
found the correct solution otherwise it
would encourage the algorithm to not
find correct Solutions but prioritize
something else so we give this reward
once the algorithm has found the correct
solution we still retain the step reward
so it means it still needs to find that
in as few steps as possible however
equal to the negative of the runtime of
the algorithm when benchmarked on a
Target Hardware so now they go and they
take a V100 GPU or a TPU
and they say you get additional reward
if your algorithm is really fast on this
particular Hardware now the algorithm
alpha or Alpha tensor has no clue
of what a V100 is or what happens in
there is a complete Black Box to it I
think they even have a diagram right
here somewhere that says black box so
but still through the power of
reinforcement learning the algorithm
manages and says well there are a lot of
a lot of algorithms with a low
decomposition a lot of them are kind of
equivalent there are thousands of
algorithms that do you know
do a decomposition of this tensor
which is another thing they mentioned in
the paper but I'll get to that in a bit
but I'm now going to search for one that
is very fast on a particular hardware
and you can see right here if we
actually
take an algorithm we tell Alpha tensor
to optimize it for a TPU then there is a
significant speed up if we measure that
on a TPU similarly if we take one that's
that we optimize we tell Alpha tends to
draw optimize for a GPU right and we get
a significant speed up not vice versa
though so you can really see the impact
that this has you can tell the algorithm
to come up with a custom tailored
solution
this is really cool and I think it's you
know this must not stay with Matrix
Matrix multiplication right you can
think of compilers working in exactly
this way right now compilers have
heuristics and rules of how they
transform source code but essentially as
long as you can prove that you're still
doing the same or I guess kinda the same
uh you can you could use these very same
techniques in order to come up with a
program with a with a uh sorry of
compile Arrangement that optimizes for a
particular hardware for a particular
metric memory speed Cycles what not
uh so there's so many applications of
this even beyond the many applications
that Matrix Matrix multiplication
already has
and if you thought well you know in
practice we have much bigger tensors
even than uh whatever 200 dimensional
and so on and these got there's got to
be some limit to the algorithm at some
point because you know this seems
compute intense then yes however even
like something small like this algorithm
here we can recursively apply it to get
speed up even at higher Dimensions so
that's pretty cool too it's not going to
be the most optimal algorithm but it's
going to be a more optimal algorithm
than we already have
so this will help at any size yeah
lastly what I want to mention is briefly
that they also say that it doesn't only
help practically it also helps a lot the
sort of mathematical view that we have
of Matrix decompositions because it
finds
it finds like for example uh if you
consider a T4 which multiplies two four
by four matrices Alpha tensor finds more
than 14
000
non-equivalent factorizations so this
means these are all different algorithms
that you can use to find uh to to to
achieve the goal of multiplying four by
four matrices to each other and they're
different they're not just like
symmetric transformations of each other
and that will I think
um yeah that is a great benefit to
mathematicians who care about complexity
Theory and things like this
all right so that is about all I had to
say about this paper so to summarize
they built this this game and the same
agent by the way plays all of these
games so the same agent trains to
multiply four by three matrices five by
five matrices and so on there's
significant transfer learning happening
so they train One agent that does
nothing else but start out with a
problem like this
augmented a little bit and then try to
find a decomposition it maybe fail it
may succeed it learns from it it tries
again finds a decomposition there's
nothing to that that's a single player
game and if you get good at the game you
can uh find good decompositions which
correspond to algorithms to multiply two
matrices
if you take very few steps in doing so
that means every step corresponds to one
multiplication in the resulting
algorithm
so if you're very good at it your
algorithms will have very few steps and
therefore
our Hardware will be able to compute it
more quickly because they have to do
less of the expensive operation that is
multiplication all right that was it for
me let me know what you think there's
more to this paper I invite you to read
it uh I hope I got the gist of it across
bye